hey everyone Mickey Mouse here happy
60th anniversary to Disneyland theme
park mi c ke y mo l SC Mickey Mouse
that's me [ __ ]
Cheers just drinking a little New Castle
because hello Sleeping Beauty's castle
did I have to explain oh how the years
fly by huh what's what's what there are
some photos of the years Charlie seems
like only yesterday that this park was
built isn't that funny how I'll never
die but you will Wow take a look at that
there is my homie G oh boy look at me
when the park opened
what a horrible outfit I'm looking
straight at her boo how is this kid not
afraid of me oh dear pan I remember
making out with many plenty of times on
their Autopia remember this look at that
kid go oh boy here's a more modern photo
of Autopia look at goofy what a coup at
war Oh Oh a madhouse Tea Party so many
memories of me growing up on this ride
Oh Snow White what a funny white girl
huh
Mickey's feeling really warm and maybe a
little party where's Minnie get over
here
oh wait I don't have a PP Oh Jungle
Cruise
now's old one-two and guess what
they still had shitty jokes on the
opening day and as the years went by
fantasmic was created in the early 90s
oh I think this is my best performance
yet
oh by far my favorite ride ever invented
at Disneyland Indiana Jones the snake
scares me every single time man I've
peed a little in my pants always oh and
I just love the smell of Indiana Jones
there is giving us a little striptease
there I'm just teasing oh here's a nice
photo of the gang having some fun what
the hell you doing buddy you look like a
really lost boy there ah there's the
whole game in our jammies I love it I
love my PJs oh I just loved when the
Jedi training academy came to the park
you can fight with Darth Vader I mean
holy [ __ ] you here are in for Christmas
Oh this is one of my favorite photos of
myself I have mad swag walking down that
Main Street oh what a nice photo of
Minnie and I that ho will do anything I
ask
when new wish upon makes oh you actually
know this there's a big difference
there's a big difference if you if you
have the right connections or family
connections with the dreams that you
have you get there a lot sooner than the
whole lives that have to go through the
whole life trying to achieve their
dreams what I can happen just got to
take a whole long time well folks that's
all for today happy 60th anniversary it
doesn't when theme park miss you and
love you Walt